i'm here with professor richard heyer
who has studied
the neuroscience of intelligence for
40 years or so is that correct 40 years
or more it's not quite clear to me but a
long time
right so what are you working on these
days well
um i just a couple of months ago
finished the manuscript for a
new textbook called the science of human
intelligence and so
it was the my latest review
of the research literature um
so actually this is the third book um
i've only i wrote the first book after i
retired
uh that was the uh the neuroscience of
intelligence book
right and that came out uh at the very
end of 2016
2017 and then
i have edited a book with some
colleagues
called intelligence and cognitive
neuroscience it's a cambridge handbook
okay that is due to come out sometime uh
early in 2021 and the textbook the
science of human
intelligence with my colleague and
friend roberto
collum that is due out sometime in 2021
also
so those are textbooks isn't those those
are for university students
um yes they're the um
the handbook of intelligence and
cognitive neuroscience
is for more advanced students and the
science of human intelligence will be
an introductory textbook and the
neuroscience of intelligence which is
out now for a couple of years that was
intended as an introductory text for
students but also i wrote it
for the public as well and it's had a
very nice
public uh response actually right now
this book which
i'm gonna put a link in the description
i recommend for the people who watch
if you're interested in intelligence at
all especially if you have no idea
this is a superlative book i read cover
to cover and i don't say that often
i just a bit of a background on me i'm
uh
matt my background's in math
mathematical physics in university
and i pretty much stayed narrowly in
that field even narrow in that field to
the theoretical side
so i know virtually nothing outside that
and
this takes someone like me who knows a
smidgen or modicum about
neuroscience and intelligence to getting
a surveillance of the entire field it's
almost like the bell curve of the
of 2015 except minus the controversy
well it's interesting you should say
that um
charles murray one of the authors of the
bell curve is a friend of mine
and he endorsed the book
and the controversy about the bell curve
is largely
misplaced shall we say a lot of people
who never read the book
think they know what's in it and react
to what they think they know what's in
it
but in fact when you actually read the
book and see what's in it it's nothing
like it's been portrayed
right this is another whole side issue
we can spend an hour talking about that
yeah okay forget about that the the book
also has
humor injected in it and i haven't heard
that
mentioned in any of the reviews and i
found myself chuckling aloud which is
again rare for me i i this is fantastic
that you appreciate that
because either some people didn't notice
the humor
or i just couldn't quite figure out if i
was really trying to be funny
and there's even you can you can see
yourself thinking aloud in the book so
for example there's one
section where you say i'm paraphrasing
something like there is no hope and then
the next section next sentence is
actually wait there is a study just came
out so on and so on
okay just so you know one of my favorite
parts was
at the end where you admit your own bias
and you may admit it in the front too
your bias towards the genetic
influence towards intelligence but it's
not just based on
your own proclivities or your own
pensions it's based on 40 years of
research
and you say this which i'm going to read
so
it's one of the last lines it says i
challenge you to think critically about
the studies i've presented throughout
this book as representative of
neuroscience progress and about what i
think they mean
my challenge to you is to find the weak
links and loopholes in my presentation
and when i do
then you design a new research study and
fix them or falsify them now that to me
says that you're a true scientist you're
saying hey here are my theories
they i think they're largely correct but
maybe they're not please
go show me where they're false and do
the studies
well you know to be honest it's not even
that i think they're mostly correct i
don't
know if they're correct the theories
came from the empirical observations
and it represents our best guess of what
might be true
but they're formulated in a way that
that creates testable hypotheses
and so over the years a lot of other
people
interested in intelligence have found
those theories of interest
and they've tested many of the
hypotheses
one of the things i note up front in the
book is what i call my three laws
number one no story about the brain is
simple
number two no one study is definitive
and number three almost most importantly
it takes many years to sort out
inconsistent and conflicting data from
different studies
to establish a weight of evidence on any
particular
question and we are now at this stage
where some of the things i proposed
as much more than 20 years ago have been
tested
there are inconsistent results there are
contradictory results but an emerging
weight
of evidence is apparent to people in the
field
and sometimes it supports the original
formulation sometimes it doesn't
i was at a meeting a couple years ago
where
a terrific researcher
professor bastin from germany
gave a talk on the brain efficiency
hypothesis
right and she reviewed all the evidence
as
she saw it what year was this this was
uh
geez about three years ago i think it
was a meeting in edinburgh
and she concluded that the evidence
for the brain efficiency hypothesis
at best wasn't so strong she was very
diplomatic
and uh so i you know i was in the
audience i raised my hand and i said you
might be wondering what it feels like to
be sitting in the audience hearing your
one of your key you know
theories being discussed
and with not too much enthusiasm
and so she you know started to laugh and
i said i'll tell you what it feels like
it feels fantastic it's a it was a
hypothesis
it doesn't matter you know what i
thought whether i thought it was correct
or not it's an empirical question
and all the research that has come out
since
we've discovered all kinds of
interesting things that we didn't know
before from that research so it's not
whether it's right or wrong
all hypotheses are meant to be tested
and then you
formulate new hypotheses and new
theories
based on the new kinds of data and
what's interesting to me
about this field is when i started doing
brain imaging studies of
intelligence in the late 1980s
i was one of the few psychologists who
had any
access to brain imaging technology
at that time it was positron emission
tomography
this was 12 years before fmri
became available to most places
and we were making everything up there
was no canned
software to analyze the images there was
no database of
images we could access not only did we
have to pay for every scan we got
with pet it was twenty five hundred
dollars per scan
we had to buy the scanner
more than how much was that more than a
million
and because pet used short-lived radio
isotopes
we had a biocyclotron we had to buy our
own cyclotron
so i spent many many years fundraising
for the capital equipment we needed
to get a few scans and at that time if
we could do a sample size of eight
people these were the first eight people
ever scanned in an intelligence
test and everything we saw was
fantastically interesting no one had
ever
seen brain function in this way before
and so when in our very first study when
we found
inverse correlations between glucose
metabolic rate in the brain which is
what
pet assessed and scores on a non-verbal
abstract reasoning
test of intelligence that was amazing it
was very surprising it's not what we
expected
and it was thrilling actually even
though the sample size was
eight now you can access
public databases of brain images and get
a thousand people
and it doesn't cost you anything for the
for the public for the audience for the
people listening do you mind
outlining what is the brain efficiency
hypothesis also
also please let people know the
advantages and disadvantages to pet
versus mri i'm not sure
i remember i'm going off of this book so
i know what it was in the 1980s and the
1990s but i don't know if those have
been fixed if there's any new
technologies any new
connections innovations yes i i lost the
threat of the point i wanted to make
i'll answer your question but the point
i wanted to make
is that you know the 1980s
35 years ago this is a whole generation
some of the people i listen to when i go
to talks now literally were not
born when i was doing this and
i could not imagine then the kinds of
technology
that's being brought to bear on the
brain efficiency hypothesis
and i think people in the field
the young people in the field need to
think about what the field is going to
be like
35 years from now i won't be here but
it's going to be
fantastic even though what they're doing
today
is fantastic and they need to start
thinking
about what's what's coming with the
technology that's coming in the kinds of
questions they're going to ask
so in 1988 positron emission tomography
was brand new
it was available in only a handful of
universities
and that's why i came to the university
of california at irvine because i had an
opportunity to work with people who
acquired a pet scan machine
here and pet
works by um injecting a radioactive
tracer
into a person while they're doing a
cognitive task
and the tracer labels those hearts parts
of the brain that we're taking up the
most glucose
that we're using the most energy and
then
you can make a picture of the um
the places in the brain that took up the
most of the radioactive tracer
because the parts of the brain that are
working the hardest
would take up the most glucose and give
off the most
radio activity to make the picture from
and the very first study we did we were
interested in what parts of the brain
were most active
while people were literally solving
intelligence test items
they were non-verbal abstract reasoning
problems and we found
some areas of the brain compared to some
control conditions
were more active while people solved the
problems
but the surprising thing was when you
correlated the amount of glucose
activity
in those parts of the brain that were
more active
to the scores people got on the
intelligence test
the correlations were inverse that is
the people whose brains were working the
hardest
had the lowest scores hence the brain
efficiency hypothesis
that it's not how hard your brain was
working that made you
score high on the test it was how
efficiently
your brain was working that's how we
explained the inverse correlations in
1988
and and that was the origin of a lot of
subsequent research
on the direction of correlations between
brain
activity measured by pet measured by
functional mri and scores on
intelligence tests between 1988
and the year 2000 not much happened in
brain imaging studies of intelligence
pet was a very complicated and expensive
technology
it was not available in many places but
around the year 2000
functional mri became available
although mri machines have been around
for a while
getting functional information in terms
of blood flow
out of an mri scanner start to be
started to become available
around 2000 and then a remarkable thing
happened
a bunch of cognitive psychologists
who were really not so much interested
in brain location
but we're interested in how the brain
processes information irrespective of
the brain areas involved
fmri was readily available in many
institutions
in the medical school so a lot of
cognitive psychologists
started getting access to fmri
and they started doing fmri studies of
cognition
and some of that included tests of
intelligence
so there it's kind of a watershed moment
in cognitive psychology
where people who traditionally were
uninterested in
individual differences became in
individual difference researchers
and now we have a lot of the most
sophisticated
brain imaging studies and intelligence
being done by sophisticated brain
imaging people
who were never really came up through
the ranks of intelligence research
so the whole field is is very exciting a
lot of new
ideas a lot of new technology and it's
this is not your grandfather's uh
intelligence research you know that was
all
paper and pencil iq test scores are iq
scores meaningful at all aren't they
just biased
and those controversies are long gone
long gone in your field but to the
general public
it's still it's still a touchy issue in
fact you even mentioned that
some researchers say we're measuring
reasoning
and they don't mention intelligence
because maybe the grant providers will
be more likely to give funding to people
who don't study intelligence because of
the the stigma attached to it
the stigma attached to intelligence came
about
almost overnight there was a time when
educational tended to be experts in
psychometrics and things like
intelligence testing as i actually
explained in the book
the watershed moment was the publication
of an article by an educational
psychologist named
arthur jensen published an article in
the harvard educational
review in 1969 he had been asked to
review
programs that were designed
to help disadvantaged children
close the gap on cognitive testing
it had been known for decades that many
uh
disadvantaged children start this was
before head start head start
started just about the time but it was
too new to be included in his evaluation
but there were demonstration projects
that helped lead to that
head start and some of those
demonstration
projects were claiming
gigantic increases in children's
iq after an intervention
right after what they called
compensatory
education and it was like
remarkable one of them was actually
called the miracle in milwaukee
right and jensen was asked by the
editors of the harvard educational
review to get the data look into it and
and just see
what was going on because these these
reports were so
phenomenal and encouraging and supported
what almost
every psychologist at the time believed
that that gaps in cognitive testing were
due entirely to being disadvantaged
and that if you could con
compensate for the disadvantage
those gaps would go away and that's why
they called it compensatory education
and what jensen found as he actually got
data and looked into
this that from a statistical
psychometric point of view
none of the claims held up none of them
and it was very disappointing but then
he went further and said look
the fact that intelligence seems to be
so
resistant to efforts to improve it by
making environmental education
changes this suggests that genetics
plays a more powerful role in
intelligence differences among people
than we have considered before
and that was bad enough but then he went
further and applied that reasoning to
the well-known
historical average difference between
black students and white students
so jensen did that jensen did that all
in this one article it's over a hundred
pages long
and it's technical and he basically
said we should consider as a hypothesis
that part of this average group
difference might be due to genetics
he didn't conclude it he didn't state it
he said this is uh some hypothesis we
should
consider he then went on to say in part
of the article that no one ever
cites that what this might mean
is that education has to be tailored to
individual students
strengths and weaknesses so that every
student can benefit
from the to maximize their education by
concentrating on their strengths
essentially
i think i cite that concluding paragraph
in the book
you held up well anyway this created a
firestorm because all people
heard was compensatory education doesn't
work
because uh intelligence is
genetic and so is the black and white
differences due to genetics
and since genetics is deterministic and
we can't do anything about it
it means that at least one group is
genetically inferior and you can imagine
that this went over very poorly
jensen uh was hounded for this
he couldn't speak at a meeting of the
american psychological association he
couldn't give an address
i actually went as a student to hear him
and the room was cleared because of a
bomb threat
and he had to basically uh
have the university police escort him
around the berkeley campus
his mail was checked by the police i
mean
you can't really imagine the backlash
against this article
and against the view that we should
consider the hypothesis that genetics
had something
to do with average group differences
it's still
a hot button issue today we need to
make clear for the people listening that
during the course of this
conversation when we're talking about
intelligence it may seem as if we're
saying that
because having more intelligence seems
to be better overall
it increases your we can talk about the
the benefits later that if you have low
intelligence then you're lesser of a
human or that you're worth less
no intelligence researcher that i know
and i know
a quite a number of them has ever
entertained that thought
i don't there are people who clearly
believe right i'm just saying that
there's the perception that when we talk
about something like this that we're
holding that belief unstable part of
what intelligence researchers have to do
is just say how silly that belief
would be so having uh
low and we haven't really talked about
it
what intelligence is right we have to
define it we have to delineate it
between
iq intelligence and g factor yeah for
the purposes of this conversation
intelligence is very
narrowly defined as a general ability
that underlies all other mental
abilities
it's not one particular thing it's a
general ability
and it's not the general ability itself
is not the only
aspect of intelligence but it turns out
to be the most predictive
of academic success job success
and life success in general that's why
most intelligence researchers focus on
it
and it's estimated by iq tests
there's no uh uh definitive
measure of intelligence like there is
for
uh temperature or distance
so as i explained in the book
ten feet is exactly twice
as long as five feet right a ratio
measure
of 140 is not twice as smart as an iq
with 70.
it's a different metric there is no
metric in intelligence research
comparable to weight or distance
is there a weight scale is there a way
to develop the ratio scale with
chronometry people that is assessing
reaction time
people we're getting ahead of the story
but people have
have dreamed about that so far it
hasn't come to fruition reaction time is
a possibility
because 500 milliseconds is
twice as slow as 250 milliseconds
and reaction time to brain events has
been used
but so far it's and it is correlated
with
iq scores and other measures of
intelligence
but so far it hasn't really broken
through as an
independent or alternative measure
of general intelligence but even with
the limitations we have
of estimating general intelligence
researchers have still learned a lot
about what intelligence is and where it
comes from
if you score low on an iq test
uh and because you don't have this
generalized ability
it means absolutely nothing about your
quality of
it it means nothing about the quality of
what kind of person you are
you can be a kind person you can be
a loyal person you can be a likable
person you can be a friendly person
and on the opposite end you can have a
high iq and be none of those things
so i think part of the problem
is that many people who are interested
in iq
or discuss it don't
have personal experience
with people at the lower end
unless you have a relative or you grew
up with somebody
with a with an iq of around 80 or less
you have no idea what life is like for
them
and and how difficult it is somebody
wants a defined uh
life uh everyday life is a is an iq test
just navigating the trials and
tribulations of everyday life
uh probably most of the people you know
are at the higher end of the spectrum
and if your average iq most of the
people you know
are you know plus or minus uh
and you don't really know what it's like
to have an iq
of of 80 or even 85 and i
people with iqs of 85 and less are the
lower 16
at the lower 16th percentile
so if you think about iq as a percentile
you know if you have an iq of 130
you're in about the top two percent
people if if you have an iq
of of 85 or less you're in the bottom
16th percentile and people
in that range with some exceptions
find it very difficult to have
the kind of employment that pays enough
to be self-sufficient they're
chronically underemployed
okay is this a problem
well the 16th percentile in the united
states with 320 million some odd people
this means over 50 million people in the
united states have iqs of 85 or less
this is a problem it's not a problem
because they're bad people it's not a
problem because they're lazy people
it's not a problem for any negative
reason about them through no fault of
their own
they have mental abilities that
limit their participation in modern
society
so what do you what how can you help
this well there are two ways you can
provide
safety nets i mean this is partly the
reason i've come around to the universal
basic income idea
that there are some people who really
really
need this and through no fault of their
own just can't earn
enough to be self-efficient but the
other way to approach it
is to say well what can we do to raise
iq
what can we do to increase people's
general ability
is there anything compensatory education
doesn't work it's been tried you know
jensen said it didn't work based on what
he did in 1969
here we are 50 years later there have
been all kinds of compensatory education
programs including head start
and others and they do
some positive things you get positive
outcomes
from them they're worth doing
but one of the positive outcomes is not
increasing their iq right q of students
so and we don't call it compensatory
education anymore
we call it early childhood education
completely change in in name partly as a
recognition that it
failed to increase iq is there anything
we can do to increase
iq in my view when i go through this
chapter and verse in
the book so far nothing has worked
many claims about memory training
computer games
in my view the way to increase iq
will come from an understanding of the
neuroscience and genetics of
intelligence
and ironically the more differences
among people
in intelligence are genetic
that means there's an underlying
biochemistry
which is ironic because in the 21st
century
we are learning how to manipulate that
kind of bio
that kind of neurochemistry
and that tells me that it's going to be
possible
once we have a better understanding of
the of the neuroscience of intelligence
to use neuroscience methods to develop
interventions possibly medications or
drugs
that would increase iq that's the ironic
part
people think that if intelligence is
genetic it's immutable
can change that's the wrong way to look
at genetics
genetics is probabilistic not
necessarily deterministic
and if you can manipulate those
probabilities by
manipulating somewhere in the cascade of
events between a gene turning on
and something happening in the brain
there's a thousand steps
a thousand neurochemical steps in
between and many
interactions of other genes and other uh
uh you know events in the brain
um if you we get some understanding of
that
we can possibly intervene to increase
intelligence dramatically
that's why i say in the beginning of the
book
in my view the ultimate purpose of
intelligence research
is to be able to increase intelligence
that's why we do this kind of research
it's somewhat controversial point of
view but that's what i think
does brain training like lumosity and so
on those
games do they help with it with an
increase in iq
no okay
how about paracetam that's a nootropic
some people say it increases their iq
have you heard any research on that
i've seen no research on
neurotropic drugs brain training
computer games that suggests an increase
of the general intellectual ability
factor the g
factor what about dual n-back training i
heard that that was associated with an
increase in working memory i think you
do outline that in the book itself
the original study was extremely flawed
i go through it in the book subsequent
studies
are less flawed but the only people that
seem to
replicate the finding at all are the
original researchers
that independent researchers have
essentially been unable to replicate
this finding and even the original
researchers
have kind of backed off the claim that
they're changing
the g factor they're changing fluid
intelligence
it might be that such training increases
attention
maybe makes visual spatial
ability go up a little bit not so clear
but in terms of really affecting what we
call
the general intelligence factor which is
the core
key factor i don't know any evidence of
it
uh i've gone on record saying the
original report was like the original
report of cold
fusion it was done by people
who were really not experts in the field
and uh kind of over hyped their own uh
data and and the original report was
seriously flawed
how about electromagnetic stimulation
like transcranial direct current
and there's a lot of pemf like like this
little device oh you have one this isn't
uh a tdcs one this is a p
e m f it's neo rhythm i don't find that
it makes me any
any brighter in the least but i wear it
when i'm trying to concentrate
has there been any research i don't know
research on that particular device
the last time i reviewed the
brain stimulation research uh
the evidence there was some positive
evidence but the weight of evidence
seemed to be negative
negative thing oh okay okay
it decreased your iq uh there was one
study that
that claimed a decrease but that was
only one study
i don't know that there has been an
evolving weight of
of evidence um you know this
transcranial magnetic stimulation and
other
ways to stimulate the brain they're very
interesting
uh they should do something but whether
they can be used to
increase intelligence
as i have defined it right right i'm not
certain of i i don't know of any
evidence that i would
say would would be compelling but
remember my third law it takes
many years to write this out and figure
it out
um i i don't recommend meanwhile that
people make their own devices to
stimulate their own brains
like some gamers were doing a few years
ago
i myself would not do that i heard that
darpa uses
tdsc for sniper training that it
increases their rate of learning which
to me seems like it would increase your
crystalline intelligence have you seen
any results that are solid in that
domain
i know the people who did that or at
least did some of that original research
it's very interesting
interesting research i guess darpa
decided not to pursue it
i don't think the effects were very big
and they were effects on really
increasing the speed
that analysts could learn material or
increase
the speed that image analog
that people that were doing image
analysis that humans
doing image analysis could could do
more of it in a shorter period of time
but again in terms of increasing
intelligence
these are these are interesting research
questions i don't rule it out but so far
let me put it this way if there was
something i knew about that could
increase my intelligence
i'd be using it right something that's
interesting
is that there's a study i think it's in
the book a fairly established phenomenon
is that the nucleus accumbens the
caudate the putamen
the morphology of it is associated with
an increase or a high rate of
fluid intelligence but only in the right
hemisphere
all of this research on localization
or identifying parts of the brain that
are related to
intelligence test scores this is
something we started
in 1988 it's been done a lot
but as i pointed out even in 1988
finding these little spots in the brain
where there's some
connection to intelligence that's just
the starting point
you have to find out what it is about
those spots
is it more neurons more dendrites
different kinds of neurons more glial
cells you know what's going on in those
areas
and moreover it's probably
as important to know how those areas
communicate with each other
right that's your p-fit model the p-4
the pariah
parietal frontal integration theory
where based on uh all the imaging
studies we could find in 2007.
actually 2006 it was published in 2007
all the imaging studies of reasoning or
intelligence
we looked at all the brain areas that
were implicated we looked at pet studies
we looked at fmri studies
and uh the way we looked at this
these findings you know in all the
studies we had different nomenclature
and different
tasks and different technology
but the commonalities we could find seem
to implicate
areas mostly in the frontal and parietal
lobes
not exclusively but mostly and so we
develop what we call the parietal
frontal integration theory
of how information flowed around those
areas
that would be related to individual
differences
in intelligence that some people might
have white matter or dendrites
or even mitochondria something different
that would allow information to flow
more efficiently while people were
processing problem solving
and that they would could pro they could
problem solve
better and faster than other people
and this at the time there was no way to
go
to really measure information flow
you could do it indirectly with reaction
time
subsequently with fmri and something
called
magnetoencephalograph
you could get such measurements now fmri
connectivity analysis is looking at this
kind of thing
these are techniques that were not
available in 2007
this is partly why i said at the
beginning that the technology
is is moving ahead so quickly and
allowing you to ask questions
you couldn't really you could ask them
you couldn't really answer before
so now they're the people doing the most
interesting intelligence
research with brain imaging are the
people looking at
how brain areas are connected to each
other
with white matter and how information
flows around those areas using
functional mri
and a lot of it is while the person is
just resting
with their eyes closed but it's going to
be more interesting
as this research is done while the
person is solving cognitive tasks
so there's a lot of interesting things
um
i don't like like to focus too much on
the old p fit because that was
you know that's 13 years ago and since
then we have a lot more information
the general pfit model seems to be
holding up well
right just minor modifications frontal
areas are
implicated and how they communicate
seems to be important
to help explain individual differences
in
intelligence have you found any
hemispheric differences so for example
let's say the left
dorsal lateral prefrontal cortex is more
important than
the right there seem to be some
hemispheric differences i don't
know that they've replicated all that
much one of the most surprising things
to me when we first started doing brain
imaging
was the lack of hemispheric differences
that you know everyone talks about the
left hemisphere does this the right
hemisphere
does that the truth mostly
i believe is in the communication
between the hemispheres
that almost nothing is exclusively left
or right
you know there are some language areas
that are predominantly on the left
we know this when people have strokes in
certain areas
or brain damage in certain areas they
lose some
some verbal abilities
but by and large i'm i'm
i'm underwhelmed at the hemispheric
findings so far
yeah what i found unintuitive was that
the weaker inter-hemispheric homotopic
connections
were correlated with iq that was one
study a
study out of harvard um needs some
replication
and now um one of the interesting things
that's happening
is there are so many different a net
brain image analysis techniques being
developed
that one of the problems is that if you
use a certain analysis
technique you find one thing and if you
use a
different technique on the same data set
you come up with some differences
this has to be sorted out by by people
who develop
these analysis techniques this is not
unique to brain imaging
this is what happened with eeg
technology
you know this group did it this way that
group connected
uh corrected for artifacts in a
different way they had different results
this will be sorted out over time i
think uh
you just have to be patient and what's
really
nice now we've reached a stage where
brain imaging studies with the
connectome had
they tend to have very large samples
and the publications often will have a
discovery sample
and a cross-validation sample
now we're really getting into some great
science
i also heard that the thickness of the
corpus callosum is
related to iq not inversely
but that seems to go against the inter
hemisphere connection in my estimation
now the quantity yeah that's those are
that's the bundle of fibers that connect
the right and left hemispheres
in some people it's bigger than others
it seems to be bigger i think in women
than in men
so what all these differences mean are
not yet clear there's there's
some conflicting data on the corpus
callosum
intelligence relationship
but if you step back when you know when
i started studying
intelligence in the 1970s
the big question was are genetics
involved
or not now we're finding
genes you know we're
much more sophisticated a big question
was are
our iq scores meaningful or are they
random numbers basically well we
know that iq scores correlate to brain
parameters like thickness of the cortex
or the activity in this area or the
activity in that area
so we we we've learned a tremendous
amount
about intelligence um
and uh the field has really moved way
beyond
uh a lot of those early questions have
been answered definitively
you know genetic in about genetics for
example
and now we're in a very uh exciting
stage
of working out details and the details
are
phenomenally complex
phenomenally complex but you know i i
there are some people who say you know
the genetics of intelligence is so
complex we'll never
figure it out because there are maybe a
thousand genes involved and they all
interact with each other and some of
them interact with environmental
factors that we're never going to figure
this out
and my answer is if physicists
like you can figure out what happened in
the first
nine nanoseconds of the big bang
then we can figure out these complex
relationships
and the way the field is evolving in
technology
and data analysis
i think we'll get there at some point i
hope i live to see it
but i don't think i think it's a finite
problem i don't think it's an
infinite problem right and you see that
progress has been made so you just
extrapolate that forward
in my lifetime incredible progress
has been made and that's why i want
young people in their 20s and 30s doing
intelligence research
to think 40 years ahead
what is it going to be like in 40 years
will we
have enough knowledge about the
neuroscience of intelligence
to tweak what goes on in the brain will
we be able to take someone with an iq of
80
and get it up to 85. that would be a
huge change for that person
and for a number of social problems
not just poverty some people are going
to live in poverty because they
cannot through no fault of their own
compete in the modern world for
jobs that pay enough and that's why i
mentioned universal
basic income on the other hand
imagine if you have an iq of 130
and you can get up to 135 you're going
to be more productive in your
profession the probability will increase
that you'll be yes yeah yeah
there's more the audience of course for
some of the people who are still like iq
is just a number why don't you
talk about the correlates between high
iq and then what are the life outcomes
and then low iq
like for example 100 166 times more
likely to drop out of high school
some phenomenal number if you have a
lower
there's really no question that for most
metrics of success that people care
about
more intelligence is better than less
it doesn't i'm better i don't mean
in a um inferior superior
kind of moral view i mean in terms of
increasing the probability of your
success
there's no i said before there's no
relationship
between moral character and iq
no essential relation you can make
something is there
is there a psychometric test for moral
character like there is for iq
um there are
tests that measure moral maturity
moral development
and they can be related empirically to
iq a little bit
but i don't see any real practical
relationship there
um so i think for the purposes of
discussing
does iq have value you have to
put aside the idea that people with
higher
iq are better than people with less high
iq
even though more intelligence is better
than
less it's like being taller it might
in many circumstances be is better than
being
shorter it doesn't mean that taller
people have a higher
moral value in some way
i think there's there i understand that
there's empirical research
that shows that better looking people
are more successful
doesn't mean they're better in any way
right as far as i know i have not been a
subject in such a study
but you know we take the world as we
find it there are these
these things that float around but in
terms of intelligence
more generally is better than less okay
on page 168 you say
that to advance the field the study of
intelligence it can't be limited to
psychometric scores of the past
but what i'm wondering is why not
because the raven's advanced progressive
matrices
seems to be a wonderful test of iq
um it is it's the ravens
test is a matrix test where you have to
reason out what
elements of the matrix are i'll overlay
some
images right now for people um and
that's a good
that's a high g test not a perfect
g test but that it's a high g test
and it would be better if we could
could develop a ratio scale it's still a
cycle
yeah but it's a good one and people use
it a lot
and uh of course critics will say well
who cares if you can solve this kind of
problem it has no relationship to the
real world
but in fact empirically it does people
who can solve those problems
do better at certain kinds of
professions
you know not everyone uh
competes within a profession equally
so in physics for example
there are really brilliant physicists
and just really smart physicists
and as a physicist you probably without
hesitation
could name the really brilliant ones and
you would get
nearly a hundred percent agreement right
from other physicists
except among the brilliant ones they
might they might disagree who's most
brilliant
right right right right now what's a
white matter integrity and what's its
relationship to iq
is it just defense against damage or
something different
the brain has gray matter and white
matter the white matter
the gray matter is like the processing
parts of the brain
the white matter are the fibers that
connect uh
brain areas to each other yeah and
they're like bundles of fibers
literally yes so the integrity of those
fibers
related to the integrity of processing
information
think about if you have a very uh if you
have a lot of white matter fibers
connecting two areas
the communication between those two
areas might be more efficient
than if you had fewer connections
and there are a couple of studies of
white matter
integrity you can measure white matter
integrity
uh with an imaging technology called
diffusion
tensor imaging and there are some new
versions of that i understand that are
even better than the person i know about
that's this right here yeah and it's
that
particular technique is excellent
at imaging these connections
and you can follow these connections and
see what areas are connected best to
other areas
and it turns out that metrics of white
matter
integrity are correlated with things
like
iq scores what about gray matter
integrity is there a measure of that
there are measures of gray matter volume
the thickness of the cortex
and some of these measures also are
related to
intelligence brain
size is related to intelligence
whether that correlation is due to more
neurons
more densely packed neurons
more white matter all of these things
are
being investigated with ever more
sophisticated techniques
and you know the weight of evidence is
emerging that these things seem to be
predictive
why they're predictive that's kind of
the next round of research
levels of explanation you know we're
going deeper and deeper in terms of our
levels of explanation of these things
right now we're kind of still in the
descriptive phase
you also mentioned that the path length
of the frontal parietal connections are
important
now the way that so what i'm wondering
is why do path links differ at all
because there's
there's like point a to b it seems like
it's approximately the same
from here to here as it is on me than
someone else unless it makes a curve
or a fractal and you're talking about
the path length
connection i think you're referring to
studies that compared
the path length between two nearby areas
you can look at nearby areas and get an
average path
linked to nearby areas then you can look
in the same people
as to the average pathology of different
areas
of uh distant areas yeah
and it turns out one study showed that
the path length to the distant
areas which were a little weaker
actually were more predictive of iq now
that was one
study so my point is that there
are still a lot of conflicting
information about this
a lot of those early studies had smaller
sample sizes
there's now more sophisticated uh
techniques to looking at
these analyses so you know
we still don't know exactly what the
right parameters are
but we know we can measure brain
parameters
that are somehow salient to individual
differences in
intelligence and once we figure out
what those are and how they work
and where they come from then that will
open the door
to the possibilities of increasing
intelligence
i think possibly dramatically i guess
what i'm
curious about is why do the path links
between individuals differ at all
because let's just take eyebrows like
the distance between here and here on me
is approximately the same
distance as it is from here to here on
you it just depends on how you define
here to here
is it just not a b line like are they
not connected one to the other
directly straight they make a good
question
but let me answer like this
everyone's eyebrows in relation to their
eyes
their nose in relation to their eyes
their mouth
in relation to their nose their mouth in
relation to their
cheeks pretty much the same for
everybody but no two people have the
same face
right no two people have the same brains
and right as a millimeter difference
in the brain make a difference i think a
millimeter is like a mile
i see i see so who knows and it's not
just
one measurement you got trillions of
synapses
and neurons and
you know who know who's to say what
small
differences here and there might mean
on their impact on neurotransmitter
levels
on the the sensitivity of receptors
pre and postsynaptic receptors we really
don't know very much on the molecular
level
about what these small physiological
differences might
mean or what they might reflect they
might reflect deeper differences
there is vast uncharted territory in the
brain
and people who want to
explore that in relationship to
something as complex as human
intelligence
this is a formidable set of questions
have you heard of dissociative identity
disorder
or multiple personality disorder i have
okay
what i'm curious about is do the
multiple personalities have there ever
been studies where one has a drastically
higher iq than the other you know i
don't know the
answer to that i think studies of
multiple personality disorder were
fashionable a while ago and i never
really got into that literature
in your book you mentioned the finn
study of 2015 and you said it was
breathtaking
it's what you've been waiting for for 40
years do you mind outlining for the
audience what that study is and then i'm
also curious have there been that was
2015.
plenty happens in just a few years
what's new so let's go over the fin 2015
study and then we'll talk about what's
new
okay so just as i was literally
finishing the book
and the final manuscript actually had
been submitted
i asked them to send it back
because i just sent it in a day or two
before
and i wanted to add the study that i
just read the finn study
a group at yale
took a database of uh
fmri um i think it was
now i can't remember who was fmri or
structural mri
i was fmri and um
from the connectome project one of the
multi-uh
site collaborative consortia that are
pooling brain imaging data
from from various sites into big sample
sizes
and they make it available to
researchers remember earlier i said we
not only had to pay for every scan we
had to do them ourselves and we had to
buy the equipment
right now there are data sets now there
are data sets you can access with a
thousand people
and they got a couple hundred people and
they did
one of the early connectome analyses
looking at brain connections and they
found
and and they had data from a couple
hundred
individuals doing six different tasks
and what they found was the
brain connectivity was
essentially the same in each person
irrespective of what the task was
and that you could identify and this
connectivity was so unique
to that individual that it was like a
fingerprint
right and moreover
aspects of that connectivity were
correlated with iq that's what was so
exciting to me
and since that time there have been
other connectivity studies looking at
intelligence
and predicting iq
from the brain image connectivity data
i had tried to predict iq from our early
pet studies
never was successful and even from our
early
mri studies our samples were just too
small and the individual differences
were too
big and so we never were able to cross
validate any of our correlations
but now with the connectome data the
sample sizes are large
they do cross validation and
it's now possible to predict iq from
brain
images
i think the highest i've seen
might be around 15 20 percent which
doesn't seem like a lot
but this is just the beginning of this
effort
and i think um that's why it was so
exciting to me
that i always wanted to do a study where
you could predict iq
from brain images and i always knew it
was going to
have something to do with the
connectivity among brain areas
was always my intuition and sure enough
this study
seemed to demonstrate that and there
have been some replications of this
and a lot of people almost everybody
working in brain imaging now
is working with connectivity analysis
so it's very exciting and what's
groundbreaking
since what has been released what study
has come out that you're like oh man
i've been waiting for this for 40 years
45 years it's not it's no one study but
it's now that the
what's what's groundbreaking is the
ability now
to take large samples of people
with brain imaging and predict their
general intelligence from that
the optimal way is not yet clear but
there's
very clever and very sophisticated
analysis techniques
looking not just at the structure not
just its structural data how brain areas
are structurally
related but how they're functionally
related so an fmri
if you're doing some cognitive task and
this area lights up and at the same
time this area lights up in the same way
those two areas are
functionally related they may or may not
be
structurally related directly and there
may be multiple
other areas that intervene and so what
you have is a net where you identify a
network of activity and then some of
that network might be
might develop genetically some might
develop in genetic interaction
with stress or other environmental
things as
when you're a child other aspects of
that network might develop by sheer
luck and random factors during
development
these are all possibilities but the the
takeaway
is that you can predict some portion of
iq
from brain images that's what is
exciting and we're just at the beginning
of that
besides predicting iq from dna
just at the beginning of that as well i
know that each brain
in the imaging is unique to the point of
fingerprint
like you mentioned what about for twins
there are there are imaging studies that
show that twins
are pretty similar but not necessarily
that identical twins have very similar
brains but not necessarily
a hundred percent identical you would be
able to differentiate them based on the
image
i i think so i've never really looked at
it quite like that
but but even though they have uh
identical
genes as their brains develop
in the womb and thereafter there are a
lot of random events that take place
that affect brain development
so they're going to be highly similar
but not necessarily
perfectly identical right and that's
something else metric is exactly
something else people need to keep in
mind is genetics doesn't mean 100
determination
there is a probability it does some
genetic things it does so if you have
like hunting the gene for huntington's
disease
that's bad yeah i you know
um but for some a complex
trait like uh intelligence
um then there are so many other factors
that the genes become probabilistic
right like having genes that put you at
higher risk for
heart disease you're at higher risk
that's probabilistic and then we know
there are things you can do to lower
your risk even though you're not
changing the genes so you can exercise
and diet
and other environmental factors can
can influence that probability
what does it look like when a man and
woman have a have a baby
i know that's a strange question what i
mean is like the woman has an average iq
the woman has an iq the man has an iq
does the baby then just have the average
of those two generally speaking
generally speaking there's a statistical
phenomenon called regression to the mean
so if if a tall father and a tall
mother have children on average their
children will be tall but not as tall as
either parent
they're going to regress to the mean if
you have
two short parents on average their
children will be
short but not as short as the parents
and the same with intelligence it's it's
a general statistical phenomenon
but you breed two smart people together
they generally have smart kids you breed
to low iq people and they generally have
low i know that's been demonstrated in
rats
generally on average
i mean there's a lot of qualifiers there
one of the
things about genetics that's interesting
is it seems to mix up
things even within families so you can
have two bright
parents having two children one can be
very bright and the other pretty average
and the reverse can happen
because you don't both each child
inherited a different fifty percent from
each parent
i see here at the same 50 percent yeah
and they interact and it's complex
okay so there's something called
acquired cervantism
i think there's only 20 cases in the
world where people have had
brain damage and then acquired an
ability and still remain somewhat normal
you know usu you can get impaired in
other aspects like your social aspects
but
these 20 people or less than 20 people
have remained somewhat normal but
acquired
an extraordinary ability like
mathematical manipulation
is quick with them or musical
memorization is rapid as well
what i'm wondering is have you heard of
any studies
on brain damage that has increased iq
that's an excellent question i've been
asking it for years and i've
never come across a case where brain
damage
resulted in increased cognitive ability
and this acquired savanta syndrome i'm
very dubious about the cases that have
been publicized
usually we don't know anything factual
about the history
we don't know if there's a concurrent
diagnosis of autism
i'm just very skeptical of this but i
don't know of any case
of any kind of lesion or brain damage
that resulted in people scoring higher
on an iq test
the only exception seem to be there are
some cases
of brain damage or lesions or
frontal lobe dementia where people get
a bit more creative artistically right
that seems to be a real thing even
though how creative it is
sometimes is subjective um
but as far as increasing intelligence is
i have never heard of such a case you
used to be a personality researcher
i think you started out as one was that
correct uh yes was that in the book
i i researched you i don't know where i
found where i found it
but either way there's a relationship
between openness and intelligence and
there's a relationship between openness
and creativity
what is that relationship
openness is one of the uh so-called big
five
personality factors personality
dimensions
some people are just more open to
experience
than other people and the more
open you are to experience that seems to
go with higher
intelligence whether that's causal or
just
correlative i don't know
um
and generally um
personality that's the only real
personality factor that seems to be
correlated
to intelligence what was the other part
of your question
okay forget that question lsd
is known and psychedelics in general are
known to increase your openness somewhat
maybe permanently at least three months
later with some of the studies
does that mean have there been studies
that have demonstrated one's iq after
a dosage of lsd like say three months
afterwards
not while they're on the trip to my
knowledge people
have talked about being more creative
after certain drug
experiences um
i don't know systematically if this has
been studied
it may well have been i don't i don't
know
is there a relationship between iq and
synesthesia
not that i'm aware of synesthesia is a
very odd
condition where people
report seeing numbers as colors
or shapes it seems like the wiring of
the sensory parts of the brain got
scrambled in some way
it's very rare uh i'm not an expert on
it
but it's as far as i know it's unrelated
to iq
um now homosexuality is in
is related to increased openness
and increased openness is also related
to an increase in iq as you mentioned
before
so does that mean have you had have you
seen any studies that demonstrate that
homosexuality is associated with higher
iq no
how about happiness the relationship
between intelligence and happiness
if you think intelligence is hard to
measure
happiness how happy are you right now
on a scale of one to ten oh
i'm i'm so glad to be speaking
i with you to flatter you too much how
happy were you exactly 24 hours ago on a
scale of one to ten
i mean that that's about it i i'm
i'm sure i'm annoying some happiness
researchers
but it it's
a hard concept to operationalize
and and get a metric that's uh
any better than uh kind of a rating
scale
the flynn effect
what i was thinking is that you know the
way that stephen hawking did
formulated that the early universe was a
singularity was just by taking a black
hole
and extra sorry taking the expansion of
the universe and extrapolating backwards
so it's like okay if we're moving
forward by a certain amount per year
then you just go back and back and back
and back
it's more complicated than that but
either way you get to a singularity
so then i was thinking about the flynn
effect and that's maybe three points
every decade
okay so that it's something like this
but it can't be
it can't be absolutely correct because
then it would mean socrates is an iq
of of five or minus 600. yes
so what are the limitations on the flynn
effect the flint effect is the
observation
the empirical observation that
over the uh decades of the 20th century
average iq scores went up
this was discovered because you have to
re-norm iq iq scores
are based on normative values right
and every once in a while you have to
renorm the test because the raw scores
are going up
and that's called the flint effect and
whether whether you can extrapolate back
whether this has been a constant thing
unlikely whether you can extrapolate
into the future
unlikely because there are recent
studies that show the flynn effect is
largely
stopped interesting
and was it related to sorry was it
related to
increasing nutrition like the bottom
lifted right
that is one hypothesis that seems to be
a good one plus
there uh is better schooling people
kids are more exposed to visual spatial
things and
other things that uh other cognitive
abilities that might account for this
um this increase whether the
increase has been in the g factor
however
is still controversial remember an iq
score
includes the g factor plus visual
spatial
plus numerical plus some verbal
abilities
and any one of those
other than the g factor could go up and
you'd get an increasing iq score that's
not necessarily due to that underlying g
factor i see i see and so i think most
researchers believe it's still an open
question as to whether or not the flint
effect relates
to g it's a it's kind of a mysterious
phenomenon
almost everyone believes it's true that
it's a correct observation
but what it means is not so clear where
it comes from is not so clear but i
don't think
you can extrapolate it into the future
and it certainly
doesn't mean that
because iq changes generation to
generation
it can't be genetic because evolution
doesn't work that quickly
when the flynn effect was first observed
a lot of the anti-genetic people seized
on it as evidence that you see
it can't be genetic it's malleable now
we know it it's
malleable within certain limits but
whether or not
that includes the g factor is still not
so clear
what can one do to decrease their iq so
we know what to avoid
drug abuse does that permanently
decrease your iq amphetamines
well those things can cause long-term
abuse
can cause brain uh
i i want to say damage
but it it's it might not reach a
threshold
they might cause changes in the brain
that could be damaged or just more
subtle changes
and we don't really know if the more
subtle changes have an impact on
something as complex as iq
which is kind of a trait over time
if you abuse your brain
uh does that have an impact on your
reasoning ability
it could in some some cases
but again there are so many different
factors here and parameters
i don't i can't believe there's any
positive effect
on your the physiology of the brain
and people who do hallucinogens many
people
swear by the positive effect on
creativity and
expanding consciousness i don't know
about any of those things empirically
but i'm really uh unaware
of any impact that would have
other than abuse and brain damage on
um on cognitive ability
you just mentioned you just made me
light up man you mentioned consciousness
so i'm curious about the relationship
between intelligence and consciousness
just as an aside for the people
listening as well as for yourself
professor
my goal with this channel as well as
myself for the next few years
and maybe my whole life i was i'm
interested in something called the
theory of everything in physics so what
are the fundamental laws of physics
and i have a suspicion that
consciousness is related somehow and
which is completely unlike most of the
physicists who are
ardent materialists and i might maybe
materialism is true i'm
i'm just not convinced but either way
i'm exploring theories of consciousness
too so let's talk about consciousness
what heck what the heck is the
relationship between intelligence and
consciousness is it that the more
intelligent you are the more
conscious you are is there a measurement
of conscious i know you can knock it out
with anesthesia
well um you may know that i was involved
in the first
brain imaging studies of consciousness
and i did these with my colleague and
friend
mike alkire who is an anesthesiologist
and i met him when he came to me he was
a resident in the anesthesiology
department
he knew about pet scanning he said can
you help me do pet scans
in people under anesthesia
he says what i want to do is i want to
scan the same
person three times okay
once while they're conscious once when i
give them enough anesthetic drugs so
they're barely conscious
you know okay steve can you hear me and
steve says
uh yeah
okay and once while steve is completely
unconscious
because i've given him enough anesthetic
drugs so we did a series of pet studies
like this
yeah uh with a couple of different
anesthetic drugs because they're all
alleged to have different brain
mechanisms
and the question was what's the last
part of the brain to turn off
when someone loses consciousness and
what's the first part of the brain to
turn on when they regain
consciousness we published a whole
series of studies on this in the late
1990s
and since then there have been a lot of
imaging studies of
intelligence i don't think there were
any before us
and uh when you talk about consciousness
i'm talking about literal consciousness
and so there are imaging studies that
are trying to find the brain areas and
the brain networks
that underlie consciousness
by manipulating those networks with
anesthetic drugs it's an experimental
approach not just a correlation approach
and i'm not up on the latest of that i
haven't done those
projects in a while um but
one of the questions i first posed to dr
alkire as an anesthesiologist
i said when you have a clinical patient
and you are dosing them
for surgery to put them under does it
make a difference
if you know if they're what we call
mentally [ __ ] if they have
very low iqs
that is to say it made no difference
that's what you're investigating more or
less anesthetic
yeah that's an interesting question and
he had no idea
i said well is there a textbook we can
go to that will have some information on
this and he said no
this is all just kind of clinical feel
he said we don't really know how
unconscious a person
is we give them enough medication
we'll poke them with a needle at some
point to see if they respond
and that's how we know how if somebody's
deep enough for surgery
and he says we give them memory
disrupting drugs so if they wake up
during surgery they won't remember it
it's horrifying horrified horrifying
information to me
but this is the way the state of the art
was in the 1990s i'm not sure it's much
different now
there are monitors that allegedly
monitor how deeply someone is
anesthetized that is how unconscious
they
are whether these work or
very well or not i don't really know
but that's how i think about
consciousness but there's a much bigger
group of
of people who think about consciousness
in a more philosophical
uh less anesthetic sense more of a
meditation
sense yeah and i'm not aware of any
data that links
meditate in meditating to changes in
intelligence that would go with
so-called changes in
consciousness i just don't know whether
that
data exists or not speaking of
meditation some people would say
mindfulness
meditation helps them with an increase
in attention and attention
is related to intelligence it's not
synonymous with it but have you seen
any research that you find
that you find credible about mindfulness
and
iq no um
remember attention is is one component
so if you are doing an intelligence
test and you take some drug
or some manipulation like meditation
that increases your attention
you might work through the test a little
faster
whether you work through it better is
not so
clear if you work through it and you
receive the same score but you did that
faster is that not an
increase in intelligence because it
it depends on what what the test is
and uh many of the the good tests are
time limited so the more you finish
correctly right and you did mention in
the book that the timed tests
tend to be highly more highly correlated
than
not with g right because given enough
time
a lot more people can solve a lot of the
problems
but the idea is by truncating the time
you're really kind of stressing the
system
and the people who can do it very fast
tend to do better on
some of these other things i don't know
if you had a chance to look at the video
that i sent you
of joshua bach have you taken a look at
it briefly looked at it and it's not
something i know
anything about so i just you know okay
okay well i'll
outline it he was putting forth a theory
that perhaps plants are more intelligent
than humans because maybe they they
communicate clearly but it takes quite
some time
and maybe throughout the course say a
thousand years from now
we would be gone but the plants would
still be communicating and they serve as
their own hive mind or on their own
brain
in some interconnected manner and i was
curious what you think
of that theory from an intelligence
point of view given that you have a
very specific definition of intelligence
yes it has no
bearing to human intelligence and what
we study
for human intelligence and you might say
that certain instincts are more
intelligent
than humans as they've been around
millions of years
it's a it's a use of the word
intelligence
that is kind of interesting but has no
meaning to me
i see i see have you looked at the link
that i sent you about eric weinstein on
intelligence
yes i watched the whole thing okay now
that i haven't watched in quite a while
so i don't i don't actually know what
i'm gonna ask you about it but do you
mind expounding like what did you
think about his theories on intelligence
if you can even articulate them to the
audience
first that'd be great well it was a
discussion between joe
rogan and eric weinstein two very
intelligent people
talking about their views about
intelligence and it was amusing
to hear intelligent people talk about
something they had limited knowledge of
uh and uh and they were quite
opinionated about it
uh joe rogan was much seemed much more
open about it
uh eric weinstein had some interesting
views
about what uh tests mean and what uh
intelligence tests don't mean all of
which i've heard for decades i mean
for example do you mind saying some of
them some of the voices he says it
doesn't measure
everything that makes people intelligent
it's very narrow
and it doesn't include creativity for
example
and that some he's specifically talked
about
uh africa african americans being more
creative musically and iq tests don't
do that and it was a kind of a
an unfocused discussion
that threw in stuff about intelligence
and intelligence testing in almost
random ways it wasn't
a really coherent discussion about
intelligence the way you and i are
having a discussion about intelligence
so it was amusing it was a little
frustrating
because they were talking about things
uh in a way that uh intelligence
researchers would kindly say
would be unsophisticated uh and they
were talking a lot about
the race issue which made them both
uncomfortable understandably
about the average differences among
between blacks and whites specifically
on iq tests
and what this means i think they missed
the bigger point on this
if you want to uh underst if you want to
fix that difference
like compensatory education like head
start
like almost every developmental and
educational psychologist
would like to do including myself you
have to understand where the difference
comes from
if there's a genetic component to that
you got to know that
if it's a cultural problem you got to
know that
and so it's still an uncomfortable
subject most people stay away from it
and ironically the longer people the
longer scientists stay away from it
the longer the underlying problem
whatever it is
will persist have you been keeping up
with
elon musk and neuralink i've been
following it to the best of my ability
um what he's doing is very interesting
i'm not sure how much real neuroscience
there is underlying
what they're actually trying to do but
it's it's
it's worth doing this they're playing
around with something very interesting
and there might be a feature in it have
you seen anything that would increase
someone's iq
by by injecting i'm not injecting by
inserting
electrodes uh no because we don't know
where to insert them and what to tell
the electrodes to do
but doesn't mean we can't find out i
don't know if you look into
artificial intelligence but the
generalizability is what held watson
back from being
considered to be a high iq computer
let's say
that is that it was great in one domain
is there a test for iq for computers
that you know of or that you can think
of or do you have any speculations
well let's see about 15 years ago i gave
a talk
at a group
of artificial intelligence researchers
about what they might learn from people
like myself who study real human
intelligence
and my whole talk was a pitch on the g
factor
the general ability it was a pitch
on understanding the general factor the
g
factor in humans and how important
the g factor was and at the time
a lot of a lot of artificial
intelligence was trying to break
human cognition into discrete pieces
this task that task and i said the key
is how you're going to
integrate all that and that
when they did statistical analysis on
human cognition
okay so with respect to artificial
intelligence
i gave a lecture to a group of
artificial intelligence researchers
many years ago and i emphasized the g
factor
that it wasn't so much the individual
components
but how they would be related in
artificial intelligence and
i've subsequently understood that the
field of artificial intelligence is now
paying much more attention to this
general factor and algorithms that would
simulate it
what they're doing i don't really know
i'm not really up on artificial
intelligence
but you asked if there was any uh
test computer test for artificial
intelligence
um i have wanted to
ask uh compare siri
to echo and alexa
on asking them questions from an iq test
just kind of general information i would
imagine they'd score extremely high on a
ravens test
well you they couldn't do a ravens test
right because they're audio only yeah so
i mean it's an
interesting question um
there might be computer programs already
that that solve raven's problems
uh i'm not aware of it uh it seems like
it would be an easy visual input
relatively easy visual input
so yeah i don't really know that much
about artificial intelligence but my
hunch is the more they can simulate
real human intelligence uh
not an easy thing to do but that
must be where they're trying to go
i think it's in this book you mentioned
that there's some studies with rats and
the g
factor in rats now that's extremely
interesting if that's true you can
extract a g
factor from animals
not only are there stuff can you tell me
a little bit about that
um two interesting things about the g
factor there is a a good
research uh report showing
that the g factor occurs in i think it
was over
30 different cultures where they gave a
battery of tests
from which they could extract the g
factor so it's
not culturally specific it seems to be
more of a cultural universal that's
number one
number two there are animal studies
where you can have animals do various
problem-solving activities
you know and score how well they do
and then factor analyze the different
problems they do and you can come up
with a g factor that's very similar
to the g factor in humans this has been
done in rats
it's been done in guppies
uh it's uh so
interesting yeah so there's it seems to
be
this general reasoning factor in
a number of animal species now what it
means i'm not clear
but it's important for intelligence
researchers to know that this may not be
a uniquely human thing
there's that age-old question what
separates man from the beast
us from the animals do you have any
speculations any ideas
maybe humans are humans the only ones
that would sacrifice food for
intellectual stimulation
the only differences i know of are the
obvious
i i i don't know how to conceptualize an
answer to that
that question it used to be when i was
in college
people would say that tool use separated
uh humans but in an anthropology course
i took
and way back in college they were
showing
some i think with jane goodall film of
monkeys using sticks to extract termites
uh and then lick the stick so they were
using tools
um so yeah uh there are obvious
differences
but uh the brains are different uh
humans seem to have more uh cognitive
capability
especially for abstract things
so i i don't really know much professor
where can people find out more about you
where can people find out more about you
um what you're working on
uh people can go to my website
richardhire.com
you will find links to the book
the neuroscience of intelligence
they will see links to the two books in
progress
and they will see pdfs of many of my
research papers and
some links to various videos of
conversations like this one
thank you so much i appreciate it well
please send me a link to the final
version
and i enjoy talking to you it's pretty
wide-ranging
yeah that's right and it doesn't look
like i read it because i don't make a
single note in any of my books and
as if you know the personality research
i score extremely high on orderliness
which means i like things to be in their
place i don't like i don't want to
desecrate this book with my ink so i
keep it
pristine but i read a cover to cover
well i appreciate uh buy it
yeah yeah i don't recommend books i
think i think
i don't i think this might be the only
book that i'll be recommending on the
entire channel
maybe there's one other yeah i can't
recall